สวัสดีค่ะพี่เอ๋สวัสดีค่ะน้องเรียมสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียน
เย้เราเจอกันที่ไหนคะเจอกันที่ที่
comprehensible ไทยค่ะอเราเจอกันวันไหน
คะวันอาิวันนี้วันอาทิตย์ค่ะวันอาทิตย์
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 16 อ่าวันอาทิตย์
ที่ 16 นะคะใช่ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะ
เดือนเมษายนค่ะทำไมคิดเดือนเมษายนอะไรนะ
ทำไมคิดนานจังเลยเรียงน่านน่ะสิวันนี้ครู
เรมกับครูเอ๋น่ะคิดนานๆอืใชกูฟังแล้วเอ๊ะ
เอ๊แล้วก็คิดนานๆเพราะว่าเหนื่อยหรรือ
เปล่าเหนื่อยเดือนเมษายนนี่แบบร้อนแล้วก็
เหนื่อยมากน่าจะนะคะอน่าจะโอ้ว่าแล้วห้อง
ครูเอ๋ก็ร้อนมากค่ะตอนนี้โอเคปับแอร์ก่อน
โอเคปีอะไรคะครูเรียมปีพ.ศค่ะ
2566 ค.ศอะไรคะปีค.ศ 2023 ค่ะค่ะตอนนี้
เวลากี่โมงคะตอนนี้
1552 นอ่านะคะเราก็จะคุยๆคุยกันจนถึง
มย 22 หรือเปล่า 1622 โอเค 1622 นนะคะได้
เลยค่ะค่ะนี่อุ๊ยพี่เอ๋อะไรทำไมทำไมเสียง
หวานว่ะเชียวเห็นเห็นรูปข้างหลังพี่เอ๋
แล้วก็
แบบรู้สึกแบบอยากเต้นอยากเต้นอะไรหรอคะ
ครูเรืมก็ชอบเต้นคเอกบอกเอ๋กชอบดูเอ๋
เนี่ยชอบตาแล้วก็ดูนะคะหูฟังนะคะก็ใคร
เหรอพี่เอกเอาใคร
มาวันนี้เราจะมาแนะนำนักเรียนแนะนำให้รู้
จักคน 1 คนแล้วก็ก็จะคุยเกี่ยว
กับงานของเคนะคะคือจะจะจะจะมุ่งที่งานของ
เขามากกว่านะคะเพราะชื่ออะไรเชื่ออะไรเ
ชื่ออะไรน่ะเรียมเรียมจำได้เพลงของเค้า
อ่ะเพราะเรียมชอบเพลงของเชื่อเพลงอะไรที่
มันร้องอะไรอโยโย่นี่คือเสียงจากเด็ก
วัดโย่แล้วนี่คือเสียงจากเด็กวัดอะไรของ
เขานี่แหละตอนนี้นะคะกำลังดังมากเลยนะคะ
เอออ่าเป็นนักร้องนะคะนักร้องนักร้องเพลง
อะไรนะแรบ
แรบแรปนะคะชื่อเชื่อว่าจริงๆเขชื่อโอม
อ้าชื่อโอมแต่ว่าเหมือนกับเค้าไปดูอะไร
สักอย่างนึงที่เป็นแรปในเ้ายังก็เลยเอามา
รวมกันเป็นยังโอมก็เลยชื่อชื่อชื่อในวง
การวงการบันเทิงหรือวงการนักร้องเเป็นนัก
ร้องนะคะเหมือนๆกับอะไรนะไมเคลแจ็กสันก็
เป็นนักร้องใช่มั้ยอใช่ค่ะหูยนักเรียนบอก
ไมเคิเดี๋ยวๆวัยรุ่นคว่านั้นใครอ่ะใครดี
อ่ะอะไรนะที่ที่ที่ที่แคนนาดา
อะไรใครนอแคนาดานักร้องที่แคนาดาแรปเรียม
แรปจำแรปผู้หญิงได้าดีบๆอะไรน่ะแอ๋อใครอ
พี่เอ๋ไม่รู้จัก
หรอคือจริงๆเอ๋อ่ะาดีๆเอ๋เคยดูแรปหรอเคย
ดูแรปเคยดูคอนเสิร์ตแอือ่าเคยดูคอนเสิร์ต
อะไรนะอะไรนะอะไรแฮมเมอร
นะ MC
M  DC  Hammer หรือ M นักเรียนช่วยด้วย
ค่ะนักเรียนนักเรียนช่วยด้วยขอโทษโอเคลืม
ๆืไปลืมไป่ย 2 คนนี้ด้วยค่ะนักเรียนคือ
คือปกติฟังพ็อนะคะฟังล็อนะคะเป็นพอล็อนะ
คะเออเออูเพลงไทยนะคะเอ๋ชอบฟังเพลงไทยนะ
แต่แรปเนี่ยเป็นเพลงของวัยรุ่นแต่ครูเอ๋
54 อ่ะจะมาแรปกับเได้มอ้าวแล้วทำไมครู
เอ๋รู้จักยังโอมล่ะคะคือเกิดจากว่าเมื่อ
ช่วงสงกรานต์นะค่ะก็มีเวลาก็เลยเปิด
Facebook ดูแล้วก็เออะไรอ่ะ Y2K  Y2K
อีกี้แล้วก็คืออะไรก็เลยถามหลานสาวหลาน
สาวก็ออก็ยังอมไงเป็นนักร้องรับทำให้เกิด
ไวรอลเกี่ยวกับสก๊อยครูเอ๋ก็ยังโอมเป็น
ใครอ่ะอืขอโทษคือครูเอ๋อายุเกินวัยรุ่น
ใช่มะก็ยังโอมคือใครหลานสาวก็เลยบอกยัง
โอมไงก็เป็นนักร้องอุ๊ยเป็นรุ่นรุ่นลูก
หนู้ารุ่นลูกของหลานสาวหลานสาวครูเอ๋อายุ
37 อืชื่อหญิงไครูเอ๋อายุ 54 ก็ต้องเป็น
รุ่นหลานครูเอ๋ใช่
มยยังมต้องเรียกคเอกว่ายายใช่มั้ย
อืเพราะว่าเอายุ 24  24 ครูเอ๋อายุมาก
กว่า 31 ปี
ว้าวเป็นนักเรียนโรงเรียนเดียวกับครูเอ๋
อ้าครูเอ๋เรียนโรงเรียนอะไรคะโรงเรียนวัด
าตุทองค่ะ
อ้าวเด็กวัดมาค่ะอันนี้เด็กวัดเหมือนกัน
ค่ะแล้วก็เด็กวัดออเรียมได้ยินในเพลงของ
เขาว่าอะไรทาทองซาวใช่ๆอัลบั้มชื่อทาตทอง
ซาวนะคะก็ก็คือเราเรารู้จักยังโอมนิด
หน่อยก่อนนะคะนักเรียนคือยังโอมเนี่ยเค้า
ก็จริงๆเค้าเป็นเด็กเรียนเก่งนะคะเคเรียน
เก่งแต่ว่าเค้าชอบฟังเพลงเค้าก็ฟังเพลงมา
หลายอย่างมากเริทุกชนิดเลยค่ะแล้วก็ไปชอบ
ล็อกแล้วต่อมาก็ชอบฮิปฮอปแล้วเก็มาเจอแรป
พอเจอแรปเนี่ยแล้วเชอบมากเค้าก็เลยเอา
เวลาไปเขียนเพลงอืเอยากเป็นคนเขียนเพลง
ใช่มั้ยคะเค้าก็เอาเวลาน่ะไปเขียนเขียน
เพลงอ่าทำให้การเรียนน่ะดรอปลงแต่เค้า
เหมือนเหมือกับเอ่อเค้าอยากได้
คอมพิวเตอร์มาเล่นเกมมั้งแล้วคุณแม่เนี่ย
ทำงานยุ่งแล้วก็ไม่ไม่มีเวลาอ่าเค้าก็เลย
ต้องหาเงินเองเพื่อที่จะไปซื้อ
คอมพิวเตอร์แล้วก็จะเอามาเล่นเกมด้วยการ
เขนยังไงคะเขียนเพลงอ๋อเขียนเพลงใช่เขียน
เพลงพอเ้าเริ่มเขียนเพลงเนี่ยก็ทำให้การ
เรียนน่ะเกรดน้อยลงเขคโดนคุณครูบอกว่าเธอ
ทำอะไรเนี่ยอ๋อเขียนเพลงแรป
ก็ทำให้เหมือนกับคุณครูก็บอกอ้อแลบโตขึ้น
จะทำอะไรกินอืเอ้อจะทำมาหากินอะไรต้อง
เรียนต้องไอคิวดีๆแต่เขาชอบศิลปะไงเชอบ
เพลงเชอบดนตรีเค้าก็รู้สึกทำไมอ่ะเคจะ
ต้องทำมันให้สำเร็จอ่าเพราะว่าตอนนั้นแรป
ที่ประเทศไทยคนไทยก็ไม่ค่อยฟังเท่าไหร่
เนาะอย่างเอ๋บอกเลยเอ๋ก็ไม่ฟังไม่ค่อยฟัง
แรปไม่ฟังเลยอ่ะฟังนิดหน่อยน้อยมากแต่ตอน
เนี้ยชอบเห็นมครูเอกไม่คือแรปของยังโอมัน
น่าฟังมาก
อืต้องไปฟังนะคะนักเรียนนะคะฟังภาษาไทย
ไม่เข้าใจก็ไม่เป็นไรเเพราะเคมีทรัพย์
เป็นภาษาอังกฤษใช่ทาตทองซาวค่ะนักเรียน
ทองซาวพิมพ์เข้าไปใน YouTube นะคะทาตทอง
ซาว
โอเคกครูเอก็กลับมากรุงเทพฯก็ไปเปิดหาใน
YouTube แล้วก็ฟังแล้วก็เฮ้ยสนุก
อ่ะใช่ครูเอ๋แบบสนุกแล้วตอนนี้นี่ทุกคน
เนี่ยสนใจมากเลยสงกรานต์นี่เรียมคิดว่า
เรียมได้ยินเพลงคาทองซาวนี่แบบโอ้โหทุก
ที่เลยค่ะในกรุงเทพฯก็มีค่ะไม่มีมีรูปค
ตอนเด็กด็ด้วยค
เรียมตอนเด็กนี่แล้วนี่มีรูปนี้ๆๆในท่าอง
ซาเนี่ยเจะมีมิวสิคใช่มั้ยใช่มิวสิควดีโอ
อแล้วก็ก็พูดถึงอะไรนะผู้หญิงคนนึงเเรียก
ขอโทษนะคะภาษาไทยโบราณเนาะเคเรียกว่า
อีกี้อีกี้ความจริงเาชื่อกี้แหละอ่ะเค
ชื่อกี้ตอนนี้เอกก็ยังสงสัยว่าคนชื่อกี้
มีจริงๆมั้ยหรือว่าเป็นชื่อในเพลงอืมอัน
นี้ก็ไม่รู้นะฮะค่ะแต่คนเนี้คนจริงๆเ้า
ไม่ได้ชิกี้แต่เ้ามาเป็นดาราในมิวสิค
วดีโอแล้วก็อ่าเหมือนกับเป็นคนชื่อกกี้นะ
คะอ่าชนชื่อกี้ก็จะมีผมทรงเนี้ยนะฮะ
เหมือนไปซอยผมใช่ซอยผมให้เหลือผมข้างหลัง
นิดหน่อยใช่ค่ะเป็นผมเม
อ่ะก็แฟชั่นแฟชั่นของใครคะเป็นแฟชั่นของ
ยุคเรียมนะจริงเป่าเรียมเหรอเรียมเรียมก็
มีทรงผมคล้ายๆแบบนี้อืเรียมดูใน
Facebook เห็นเพื่อนๆโพสต์ใน Facebook
เรียมก็กดหัวเราะกดหัวเราะแต่เรียมก็ไม่
โพสต์รูปเรียมนะเรียมก็ไม่ๆๆทำไมอ่ะรอ
หัวเราะคนอื่นพอละต้องไปหาไงพี่เอ๋ถ้าจะ
โพสต์ต้องไปหารูปอยู่ไหนเพราะมันนานมากๆ
ค่ะก็
เอ่อจริงๆแล้วเนี่ยต้องบอกว่าดาราคนที่
แฟชั่นในเยในเพลงของเขาคเขบอกว่าเป็นอะไร
นะเค้าเรียกว่าอะไรสกอยค่ะสกอยนะคะเออ
อีกี้มันเป็นสก๊อยใช่อีกี้อีกี้อีคุณกี้
เ้าเป็นสกอยได้มั้ยไม่ได้ทำไมเรียกคุณไม่
ได้หรอคะเพราะว่าเพื่อนกอยเราไม่เรียกคุณ
เหรอคะ
เพื่อนเค้าคุยกันไงอ๋อเป็นเพื่อนกันแล้ว
ก็เป็นแบบเหมือนเด็กๆคุยกันค่ะมันเป็นคำ
ที่ไม่สุภาพนะค 13  14  15  16  17  18
เนาะประมาณนี้ใช่ๆค่ะแต่ไม่ใช่ทุกคนจะพูด
แบบนั้นนะค่ะแต่ก็มีอีกหลายคนเหมือนกัน
ที่ใช้คำพูดที่พูดกับผู้หญิงว่าอีออีกี้
ถ้าเกิดเรียกเรียมอีเรียมอย่างเงี้ยเรียม
โกธนะเรียมอือยู่ที่เสียงด้วยมั้ยน้อง
เรียม
ไม่อยู่ที่เรียมเรียมไม่เคยไม่เคยมีใคร
เรียกเรียมว่าอีอแต่เขาอาจจะคุยกันบ่อยๆ
แล้วใช้คำว่าอีจนแบบอือืไม่เป็นไรเรียก
ได้คือจริงๆอ่าถ้าเสนิทกันแล้วก็ต้องฟัง
ที่ลักษณะการใช้เสียงด้วยแหละสำหรับครู
เอ๋ว่านะเพราะว่าเวลาเอ๋ฟังฟังเพื่อนใน
กลุ่มที่เป็นเ่อสาว 2 เขาก็จะเรียกกันว่า
อีแต่เขาไม่เรียกเอเหมือนกันนะฮะเก็จะ
เรียกกันอีนี่แต่เขาจะเรียกเราพี่น้องก็
แล้วแต่นะคะหรือเรียกชื่อเฉยๆแต่ว่าเวลา
ที่สกอยเค้าเรียกกันเก็ไม่เรียกคุณน่ะ
เนาะเไม่ค่ะไม่เก็ขึ้นต้นด้วยอีนะคะอื
งั้นเนี่ยสกอยนักเรียนค่ะครูเอ๋เริ่มสนใจ
สกอยขึ้นมาทันทีครูเอครูเอ๋ไม่รู้จัก
สก๊อยเหรอคะ
เอ่อรู้จักแต่ไม่รู้จักวิถีจริงๆของสกอย
อ่ะอคือถามว่าเห็นมยก็เห็นแล้วก็ไม่เข้า
ใจว่าชีวิตสก๊อยทำอะไรแล้วทำไมถึงต้องไป
เป็นสก๊อยอ่าแล้วอืมันเหมือนกับเค้ามี
ความสุขกับสนุกกับการเป็นสก๊อยใช่มยคะแต่
แต่ต้องต้องบอกนักเรียนก่อนนะคะไม่ที่เรา
จะคุยกันไม่ได้หมายความว่าสกอยดีหรือไม่
ดีเราไม่พูดตรงนั้นนะคะเพราะว่ามันเป็น
ช่วงชีวิตหนึของคนในช่วงชีวิตวัยรุ่นหลัง
จากนั้นเนี่ยคนไปเป็นสกอยเนี่ยอาจจะมา
เป็นคุณแม่ที่ดีอาจจะประสบความสำเร็จใน
การทำงานก็ได้ใช่มั้ยคะใช่ใช่ค่ะเพราะว่า
สกอยเนี่ยเจะต้องมีอะไรนะมีมีนั่งนั่ง
ท้ายรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่มั้ยใช่ค่ะคนที่จะ
เป็นสกอยได้ต้องสวยต้องมีแฟนอ๋อสวยแฟนสวย
มั้ยไม่รู้อกูเอเป็นต้องมีแฟนนะต้องมีแฟน
เป็นผู้ชายที่ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์
อืมครูเรียมมีมอเตอร์ไซค์มั้ยคะมีค่ะ
เดี๋ยวเรียมเอาให้ดูมอเตอร์ไซค์แบบแบบนี้
อ๋อไม่ไม่ใช่ฮาเล่ใช่มั้ยไม่ไม่ใช่ค่ะไม่
ใช่ฮาเลไม่ใช่บิ๊กไบคนะอ๋อออถ้าเกิดนั่ง
บิ๊กไบคหรือนั่งฮาเล่ไม่เรียกว่าสกอยหรอค
ไม่ค่ะไม่อืไม่ได้เรียกว่าสก๋อยแต่จะเป็น
รถแบบเนี้ยก็คือแบบรถที่ราคาแบบถูกๆไม่
ค่อยแพงเท่าไหร่
อืแล้วเา้าก็เอามา
เปลี่ยนเปลี่ยนให้เหมือนแบ
ะมันเป็นยังไงเนี่ย
เค้าเรียกว่าแต่งรถใช่มั้ยใช่เาเรียกว่า
แต่งรถค่ะอืแต่งรถเหมือนยางล้อรถอย่างงี้
เขาก็จะทำให้มันบางลงทำไมอ่ะเพราะคิดว่า
ว้าวเท่จังเลยอ๋อไม่เหมือนไม่เหมือนไม่
เหมือนคนอื่น
ๆก็เอามาแต่งรถที่เขาคิดว่าอืืสวยมากเท่
มากเเท่คือรู้สึกโอไม่ไม่เหมือนใครแล้วก็
ทุกคนจะต้องมองใช่มั้ยว่าชัน
โอ้
เท่ใช่ค่ะใช่มาแต่งให้เท่แล้วก็ต้องใส่
หมวกกันน็อคมั้ยอ่ะไม่ค่ะผู้ชายที่ขับรถ
อันนี้ไม่ใส่หมวกกันน็อคใช่มั้ไม่ใส่ค่ะ
อืแล้วที่สำคัญนะคะเป็นยังไงคะ
มอเตอร์ไซค์เค้าจะมีท่อไอเสียใช่มั้ยคะ
พี่เอ๋ค่ะท่อไอเสียอาจจะเป็นแบบนี้
พ่อไอเสียอ้าเปลี่ยนสีปากกาก่อนมันมองไม่
เห็นเนี่ยโอเคข่อไอเสียที่มันจะปล่อยควัน
ออกมาค่ะเค้าก็ไปแต่งท่อไอเสียให้มัน
เสียงดังๆไปบีบมันลงจริงๆมันกลมใช่มยกลมๆ
แบบนี้แล้วก็บีบโหเค้าแบบทำหลายอย่างมาก
อันนี้เรียมแบบไม่รู้แต่รู้แต่รู้แค่ว่า
ทำให้เสียงดังดังเวลาเวลาเค้าเรียกอะไร
เบิ้ลมอเตอร์ไซค์หรอคะ
[เพลง]
หใช่ค่ะนั่นแหละคนที่จะเป็นสกอยได้ต้อง
เป็นแฟนกับคนที่ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์แบบนี้
อ้าแล้วคนที่ขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์เราเรียกว่า
อะไรเค้าเรียกว่าเด็กแว้นค่ะเเรียกว่า
เด็กแว้นนะอ๋อเด็กแว้นก็มาจากเสียงมีแฟน
ขับมอเตอร์ไซค์
ใช่ค่ะใช่แวนๆๆๆครูเดมเคยมีใครเคยมีใคร
ชวนเรี่ยมนั่งมอเตอร์ไซค์ฉันมั้ยไม่มีค่ะ
พี่เอ๋เอจิป่าเพราะว่า
อ๋อเรียนผม
ยาวน่าจะมีคนชวนนะโหแบบตอนที่อายุที่คน
อีกหลายๆคนนะเพื่อนเพื่อนหลายๆคนเป็นสกร
อืเรียมน่ะไม่ได้เป็น
สกอยเพราะว่าไม่มีแฟนอ๋อต้องมีแฟนใช่ต้อง
มีแฟนแล้วก็แบบไปนั่งไปนั่งข้างหลังรถให้
แฟนขับรถมอเตอร์ไซค์ใช่มยคนข้างหลังจะ
เป็นสก๊อยค่ะแล้วแฟชั่นสกอยก็จะประมาณนี้
นะคะนักเรียนจะประมาณนี้คือสกอยก็จะมี
สกอยในกรุงเทพฯกับสกอยต่างจังหวัดนะคะอื
เออซึ่งซึแฟชั่นผมสกอยกรุงเทพฯก็จะผมทรงเ
เนาะอืแล้วก็จะแต่ง
หน้าคล้ายๆกันนะคล้ายๆกันหรอดูแบบคล้ายๆ
กันอือเค้าจะแต่งหน้าแบบทาหน้าขาวเลยอ่ะ
น้องเรียนมีรูปมั้ยใช่ค่ะไม่มีครูเอ๋มี
รูปให้ในรูปเนี่เียมไม่ได้มีไม่ได้มีู
หน้าขาวนะขอโทษนะคะขอโทษสกอยทั่วประเทศ
ครูเอ๋วาดรูปได้เท่านี้นะ
คะคือคือหน้าเนี่ยค่ะเค้าจะทาหน้าคือสี
ของหน้ากับสีของผิวมันจะคนละเบอเหมือน
เหมือทาแป้งคนละเบอเพราะส่วนใหญ่เใช้แป้ง
ฝุ่นใช่มยก็มีแป้งฝุ่นด้วยค่ะอาจจะมีแป้ง
แบบแป้งตลับก็มีอืแป้งพับก็มา
ทาหน้าก็จะสีขาวๆนะคะอ่ะตาอตานะคือการ
เป็นสกอยนี่ไม่ง่ายนะ 1 คุณต้องทาแป้งให้
หน้าขาว 2 คุณต้องใส่บิ๊ก E เป็นคอนแทค
เลนน่ะค่ะใช่คอนแทคเลนสีดำเมมีรูปนะ
อืที่ทำให้ดูแบบตาตาดำใหญ่มากขึ้นใช่เขา
เรียกว่าเป็น IG  Eye คือทำให้ตาเนี่ยดู
โตดูใหญ่
นะคะแล้วก็ใชต้องทาทาปากและแก้มอันนี้
เป็นหน้านะค่ะทาปากและแก้มด้วยอน้ำยา
อุทัยนี่เป็นเรียกว่าน้ำยาอุทัยนักเรียน
น้ำยาอุทัยเนี่ยปกติเนี่ยเราจะมาใส่น้ำ
แล้วก็ดื่มเวลาหน้าร้อนใส่น้ำดื่มแล้วก็
จะรู้สึก้อสดชื่นว่าแล้วเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะไป
ซื้อมาใส่น้ำดื่มเนาะเนี่ยครูเอ๋พูดเรียม
ก็เลยแบบออสดชื่นเดี๋ยวไปซื้อบ้างดีกว่า
ใช่มั้ยน้ำยาอุทัยเนี่ยคือใส่น้ำดื่มใน
ช่วงหน้าร้อนดีมากทำให้ร่างกายเราไม่ร้อน
จัดนะจะสบายๆนะคะเป็นสมุนไพรนะคะกินได้
เอาไว้ใส่น้ำแล้วก็ดื่มแต่สก๊อยเ้าเอามา
ทำอะไรคะครูเรียมเขาก็จะเอามาเค้าก็ดื่ม
นะแล้วเเอามาทาปากด้วยอ๋อให้ปากเป็นสีแดง
ๆนะตอนนี้น้ำยาอุทัยก็ได้ทำแบบนี้ออกมา
ค่ะสำหรับทาปากโดยเฉพาะใช่สำหรับทาปากโดย
เฉพาะแล้วเ้าก็เอามาทาหน้า
ด้วยมาทาแก้มใช่มยพี่เอกใช่ทาแก้มแก้มแดง
แก้มกับปากก็จะสีเดียวกันนะคะอืจากน้ำยา
อุทัยนะคะอือืแล้วก็เห็นเขาบอกว่าครู
เรียมสก๊อยเนี่ยต้องดัดฟัน
ด้วยใช่ตัดฟันต้องเป็นสีด้วยนะออต้องสี
แบบนี้สิใช่สีชมพูสีเขียวบางคนก็ไม่ได้
จัดฟันจริงๆไม่ได้ดัดฟันจริงๆแต่ทำแบบ
แฟชั่นเหมือนเอามา
ติดติดแล้วก็ถอดออกได้แต่บางทีก็ถอดออก
ไม่ได้นะแต่แบบอ้าทำไมอ่ะแต่ไม่ได้แบบ
เหมือนเค้าติดไว้อ่ะ
อ๋อติดเป็นแฟชั่นเฉยๆใช่มั้ยคะติดเป็น
แฟชั่นแต่ไม่ได้จัดฟันจริงๆไม่ได้ดึงให้
ฟันสวยนะแต่แบบเอามาติดติดๆให้แบบมีหลายๆ
สีเหมือนจัดฟัน
อ๋อเป็นแฟชั่นของน้องสกอยนะคะใช่ค่ะอืมี
อีกเดี๋ยวนะครูเอ๋มีให้ดูปึ๊บแล้วก็เา้า
บอกว่าเสื้อ
ผ้าเสื้อผ้าเนี่ยจะใส่แบบเสื้อเสื้อเสื้อ
ตัวเล็ก
ๆบางคนมีรอยสักแบบนี้
อือันนี้แบบต่างจังหวัดนะคะก็จะมีรอยสัก
นะเป็นสักจริงๆนะคะเนี่ยอ่าไม่ใช่สัก
แฟชั่นนะเป็นสักแบบความเชื่อนะคะแล้วก็มี
อะไรนะต้องพกแบบนี้ค่ะครูครูเหรียญมีอะไร
บ้างเอ่ยมีอะไรบ้างคะพี่เอ๋
หวี
กระจก้าคุณหนูแป้งแป้งอาจจะเป็นแป้งพับก็
ได้นะคะอก็จะแล้วหวีนี่จะเสียบไว้ข้าง
หลังแล้วก็จะเอามาหวี
ผมใช่พี่เอ๋ไม่มีหวีไม่ได้ทำไมเพราะว่า
นั่งนั่งซ้อนท้ายเด็กแว้นไงเด็กแว้นสับ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ผมก็จะโดน
ลมรัดผมแบบคูเรียมได้มยก็รัดได้นะแต่แบบ
มันมันไม่สวยมันไม่เท่อมันไม่
เท่ให้ลมพัดไปยังไงเราก็มีหวีเราก็เอาหวี
มาหวีผมได้ใช่แล้วก็มีกระจุกดูอ้อปากไแดง
ก็น้ำยาทาต่อได้ใช่มั้ใช่ๆร้อนก็มีผ้าเ
ใช่เพราะว่ามอเตอร์ไซค์ไม่มีแอร์นะออ
ใช่วิถี
สกอยใช่แล้วอืก็เห็นแล้วสำหรับครูเอ๋เห็น
แล้วก็เป็นชีวิตอีกรูปแบบหนึ่งของวัยรุ่น
ที่เขาชอบกันเนาะแล้วที่สำคัญอีกอันนึง
รองเท้าเป็นยังไงคะครูเรียมรองเท้าเป็น
รองเท้าแบบนี้ค่ะเป็นรองเท้าแบบแตะรอง
เท้าหูหนีบ
อือ๋อแล้วเล็บต้องทาด้วยใช่มยคะใช่ค่ะ
ต้องทาเล็บด้วยทาเล็บมือทาเล็บเท้าอเอ้ย
เมื่อกี้ครููเอ๋ให้เห็นเสื้อไปแล้วกางเกง
มีมั้ยครูเรียมีรูปกางเกงกางเกงหรอกางเกง
เรียมแบบไม่ได้มีนะขาสั้นแต่แบบเป็น
กางเกงขาสั้นค่ะทุกคน
อพี่เห็นมีกางเกงมยเดี๋ยวริมวาดให้เดี๋ยว
คุยหาก่อนนะคะครูเอ๋มีมั้ยรูปกางเกงเป็น
กางเกงแบบขาสั้นแบบสั้นมาก
[เพลง]
อเป็นยีนนะคะเอาจริงๆกางเกงอะไรก็ได้อ่ะ
ค่ะนะคะกางเกงอะไรก็ได้เต้องเป็นขาได้แต่
ว่าขาสั้นมากๆค่ะเห็นเอวด้วยใช่มั้ยคะ
เห็นสะดือใช่ค่ะเห็นเอวด้วยเนี่ยมีสะดือ
อืเนี่ยค่ะแต่อาจจะสั้นกว่านี้นะอาจจะ
สั้นแบบนี้เลย
อ่ะนี่แหละค่ะ
สกอยที่ทุกคนกำลังสนใจอยู่ตอนนี้ว่าอีกี้
มันเป็นสกอยสกอยคือ
อะไรสกอยก็คือเด็กวัยรุ่นนะคะต้องต้อง
เป็นวัยรุ่นเนาะอ่าใช่ซึ่งซึ่งในเพลงนี้
เนี่ยก็จะเป็นคนนี้นะคะที่ที่ที่ที่แสดง
เป็นอีกี้นะคะก็ต้องต้องตาเนี่ยนอกจากตาโ
แล้วก็ต้องกรีดอายไลเนอร์แล้วก็ใส่ขนตา
ปลอมแล้วก็ให้ยาวๆนะคะอืเสื้อตัวเล็กๆ
เป็นเสื้อยืดนี่แหละค่ะเสื้อยืดแต่ว่าไม่
มีแขนเป็นเสื้อแขนกรุดแล้วก็เอาขึ้นมา
อุ๊บผูกอืให้ดูแบบเซ็กซี่นิดนึงใช่นะอืก็
เป็นเสาสกอยนะคะในเพลงของยังโอมตอนนี้
เนี่ยคนก็เลยสนใจเอ๊ะอสนใจเรื่องสกอยมาก
ขึ้นนะคะเ่าครูเอ๋ก็ไปดูหลายเว็บเลยอัน
นี้ก็เป็นเว็บนึงที่เขาเอามาให้ดูแล้วคน
นี้เป็นอิกกี้ในเพลงของยังโอมูเอออสกอย
อืนะฮะก็แล้วก็มีคนโพสต์รูปตัวเองนะเตรม
คิดว่า Y  to สกอยเนี่ยสกอยเนี่ยเป็นวัย
ประมาณอายุ 13 ถึงประมาณ 17  18 ปีค่ะ
เพราะว่าเป็นตอนที่ผู้หญิงยังไม่ได้ทำงาน
ยังเรียนหนังสือตอนนี้ยังมีสก๊อยมั้ยตอน
นี้มีนะคะมียังมีอยู่ใช่มั้ยคะเพราะว่ามี
สกอยอยู่สก๊อยเริ่มมีเริ่มมีตอนประมาณ
ก่อนปี 2000 เนาะประมาณปี 2000 หรือก่อน
หน้านั้นครูเอ๋ไม่แน่ใจเพราะตอนครูเอ๋วัย
รุ่นไม่มีสก๊อยอือ่าตอนครูเอบวัยรุ่นน่ะ
ไม่มีสกอยนะคะสกอยไม่มีตอนครูเอบอายุ
ประมาณซัก 30  32
33 ตอนที่ครูเอ๋อายุ 3233 เริ่มมีสกอยละ
แล้วก็มีเด็กแว้นอ่าพเอก็ไอ้เด็กแว้นนี่
คืออะไรสกคืออะไรอหูเป็นช่วงวัยที่เรียม
เนี่ยอายุ 10  13-18 ปีพอดีเรียมก็จะมี
เพื่อนเพื่อนที่เป็นเด็กเด็แว้นหรือว่ามี
น้องๆที่อายุน้อยกว่าเป็นเด็กแว้นเดมก็
เลยแบบออ
รู้อเพราะว่าเป็นช่วงที่เด็กผู้ชายมีรถ
มอเตอร์ไซค์ของตัวเองแล้วก็เริ่มแบบแต่ง
รถแล้วก็มีแฟนแฟนก็จะเป็นสก๊อยนี่แหละก็
จะเป็นสกอยเรียมคิดว่าเมื่อก่อนเรียมก็
แต่งตัวคล้ายๆสกอยนะแต่แบบไม่ได้
100% แต่แค่เลียมไม่ได้มีแฟนเป็นเด็ก
แว้นก็เลยแบบไม่ได้เป็นสก๊อยเพราะว่าถ้า
อ่าถ้าแต่งถ้าแต่งหน้าสแบบสกอยก็ต้องแบบ
นึงนะถ้าแต่งหน้าแบบอื่นแล้วมีแฟชั่น
เสื้อผ้าคล้ายสกอยเก็ไม่เรียกสก๊อยนะอืม
ใช่แต่ว่ามันคล้ายๆแต่ว่าไม่ใช่สกอยคล้าย
ๆอ่าเพราะว่าถ้าสมมุติว่าครูเรียมแต่ง
หน้าแบบทาแป้งแล้วก็ผิวสีเดียวกันแล้วถ้า
เข้าไปอยู่ในกลุ่มเด็กแว้นก็เป็นสก๊อยไม่
ได้เขาก็จะเรียกว่าคุณหนูไม่ใช่สก๊อยหรือ
อย่างครูเอ๋อ่ะตัวขาวหน้าขาวก็เป็นสกอย
ไม่ได้ใช่มออืใช่หรือว่าแบบเรียมไม่ได้
ใส่บิ๊ก E ก็เลยดูไม่เหมือนก็เหมือนสก
สกอยต้องเปรี้ยวๆหน่อยใช่มั้ยใช่แล้วปาก
แดงเรียมก็ไม่ได้ปากแดงแค่เรียมอาจจะใส่
กางเกงขาสั้นเหมือนสกอยแต่ว่าเรียมใส่
เสื้อยืดแขนสั้นไม่ใช่เสื้อแขนกุดค่ะงั้น
เพลงนี้ของยังโอมก็ดังมากตอนนี้เเอาชีวิต
ของนักเรียนวัดแล้วก็ชีวิตของสก๊อยออกมา
ว่าจริงๆแล้วสกอยเนี่ยเค้าทำงานอะไรโต
ขึ้นน่ะเทำงานอะไรบ้างหรือว่าเด็กวัด
เนี่ยเด็กวัดเนี่ยมีชีวิตยังไงเด็กวัดก็
คือเด็กนักเรียนที่เรียนโรงเรียนของวัดนะ
ฮะโโรงเรียนที่ไม่แพงนะคะใช่คุณพ่อคุณแม่
อาจจะไม่ได้มีเงินมากๆให้ลูกไปเรียนโรง
เรียนที่แพงแพนก็เรียนโรงเรียนวัดนะเด็ก
วัดเนี่ยจะสำเร็จได้มยสำเร็จคือทำงานแล้ว
มีชื่อเสียงได้มั้ยใช่มั้ยคะใช่ทำงานแล้ว
ได้เงินเยอะๆได้มยใช่งั้นน่ะยังโอมก็คือ
คนนี้นะคะนักเรียนเค้าก็ตอนนี้เนี่ยมี
เพลงที่เกี่ยวกับเด็กวัดเยใช่มั้ยคะคน
เนี้ยเป็นเพลงเพลงเกี่ยวกับเด็กวัดซึ่ง
ตอนเนี้ยในประเทศไทยมีโรงเรียนวัดเยอะ
แล้วเขาก็ไปสัมภาษณ์อ่อบางคนโอ๊เป็นนัก
เรียนวัดก็ไม่แย่ใช่มอันนี้ก็เป็นนัก
เรียนวัดที่ประสบความสำเร็จร้องเพลงรป
สำเร็จใช่มั้ยคะหรือบางคนบางคนเป็นสกอย
แต่ว่าโตขึ้นก็ทำงานดีๆก็มีเยอะใช่มั้ยคะ
ใช่ๆค่ะมันเป็นช่วงไวที่เรียมคิดว่าไม่
ได้ทำงานแล้วอยากสวยก็เลยแบบซื้อของราคา
ถูกๆแล้วก็เอามาแต่งหน้าใช่น้ำยาอุทยก็
ขวดเท่าไหร่เองไม่เกิน 50 บาทไม่ไม่แพง
ค่ะอืไม่เกิน 50 บาทใช้ได้นานมากกินก็ได้
คาก็ได้ามบาทคาแก้มได้ผิวก็เปิดขวดน้ำเท
ใส่แล้วก็ดื่มใช่ค่ะสกอยบางคนเมื่อก่อน
อาจจะเคยเป็นสกอยโตขึ้นแล้วทำงานหาเงิน
ได้เยอะๆก็จะสวยมากขึ้นสวยขึ้นสวยขึ้น
แล้วก็ไม่มีใครรู้ว่าเคยเป็นสก๊อยใช่ค่ะ
อืก็จริงๆแล้วนะเป็นแค่ชีวิตช่วงนึงของ
วัยรุ่นใช่มั้ยคะเท่านั้นแล้วยังโอมเอา
ชีวิตอันเนี้ยออกมาเป็นเพลงแรปนะฮะตอนนี้
ก็เลยคนฟังมากๆดูมากๆรวมทั้งครูเอ๋ด้วย
ชอบค่ะใช่รวมทั้งครูเรียมด้วยครูเรียมครู
เอ๋ฟังแล้วก็ชอบครูเรียมฟังชอบแล้วก็เต้น
ค่ะเต้นด้วยเหรอคะครเอนั่งดูเฉย
ๆไม่ดูไม่ได้ค่ะพี่เอ๋เวลาหมดแล้วเอ้า
เหรอ
โอเสียดายจังเลยอ่ะเดี๋ยวครูเอ๋จะไปฟัง
เพลงต่อนะคะได้ลธาตทองซาวนักเรียนธาตุทอง
ซาวได้เลยค่ะเดี๋ยวไว้เจอพี่เอ๋กับเรียม
ในวีีดีโอถัดไปนะคะค่ะได้ค่ะแล้วพบกัน
ใหม่คลิปหน้าค่ะก็เลยค่ะนักเรียนก็ฝากกด
ไลค์กดแชร์กด Subscribe กดกระดิ่งกิ๊งๆ
ให้เราด้วยนะคะใช่แล้วค่ะวันนี้ลาไปก่อน
แล้วค่ะพี่เอกบ๊ายบายค่ะ
[เพลง]
อ้อนักเรียนลองไปเปิดฟังดูนะคะาตทองซาวนะ
คะยังหาคำว่ายังโอมอ่ะค่ะ y  o  u  n  g
นะคะแล้วก็ o  m เนาะยังโออือโอเคไปจริงๆ
แล้วค่ะบ๊ายบายไปจริงๆแล้วค่ะบ๊ายบาย
สวัสดีค่ะสวัสดีค่ะ